[Music]
thank you
Freddie thank you for joining us on
spectator TV great pleasure John um I
was saying I think it seems a bit like
deja vu at the moment we're back again
talking about Trump raising criminal
charges but what are the latest
indictments and what is he facing it is
it is a little bit like from Groundhog
Day isn't it uh well the latest relate
to January 6th and special prosecutor
Jack Smith who's hounding Trump on all
sorts of fronts
um has uh brought four charges against
Donald Trump
um the main one is a conspiracy to
defraud the United States
uh and alongside that the conspiracy to
defraud the right to vote of every
American citizens and that relates to of
course Donald Trump's great tantrum
after uh the 2020 election and the way
in which according to a lot of people he
encouraged and incited uh the Riots of
January 6th which is now Infamous
um there are no Insurrection charges
which is quite some important because
probably the only way in which he could
be debarred from running from office
would be if he had been found guilty of
insurrection I didn't seem to happen
it's not a realistic possibility so you
have this situation now where Trump is
facing 78 counts 78 uh counts criminal
counts uh against him and the Civil uh
trial which is the rape case in New York
which is
seems quite spurious to a lot of people
but it's still ongoing
uh and he is still
far far ahead
in the polls to be the the Republican
nominee it's not just trumpists
who rally around him because they've
already rallied around him it's actually
quite a lot of republican-leaning
Republican people who do feel this is a
politicization of Justice who do feel
that Donald Trump has a point and when
they're asked about it in pulse they
tend to support him more
uh after one of these indictments comes
out well he mentioned he's being hounded
by Jack Smith I mean do you think
they're right to think that that at
least some of this is politically
motivated the charges against him or was
funny with Trump I always think that
what I think doesn't really matter
because I mean I think if you want to do
what I think uh I think the worst thing
Donald Trump did as president was to uh
refuse to accept the results of the 2020
election I mean Richard Nixon uh in the
1960s thought that he had been robbed of
the election by JFK and he actually had
quite good reason to think that
but he accepted the results uh and I
think it's an important part of the
democratic process even if it is a
little bit dodgy it's not totally
compromised her and you should accept uh
the result of it the fact that Donald
Trump didn't
was a bad thing uh he behaved recklessly
he did encourage people to think very
conspiritable thoughts
um and he did undermine the Democratic
process I think Americans and Brits when
we talk about Mary who can get a little
bit pompous about process we don't have
to all believe
election results you know we're not
that's not some sort of
um
divine order that we have to accept them
and the fact is Democrats have
repeatedly refused to accept election
results when Republicans win they didn't
accept Donald Trump winning They didn't
accept George W bush winning
um it it's it's slightly pompous all
that talk I think so I'd I'd try and get
away from that and then maybe look at
whether these in criminal indictments
have any value I think in this
particular case while Trump no doubt
behaved badly
uh recklessly as I said
um what the indictment needs to prove is
what it claims which is that Trump
willfully knowing that he was spreading
lies about the election
uh tried to claim that it was stolen uh
I don't think they're going to be able
to do that I don't understand Trump's
brain nobody does but the fact is I
think Trump believes the election was
dodgy and therefore the fact that he
still does uh means that you can't
really accuse him of of willfully
engaging in a conspiracy I mean do you
get a sense though this could all very
much backfire for Trump's enemies in the
sense that if he gets off these
particular criminal charges he will
certainly see that as a Vindication of
his actions on January 6th it's very
hard to say I mean given the number of
uh charges in these indictments it's
possible that he will go down for him
will he go down in time for the election
that's a difficult question to answer
um if he does and runs from prison could
he run a successful campaign
constitutionally he could you can run
from behind bars Eugene Debs did it in
the 1920s he won a million votes
um so all sorts of impulables are going
on here what do you think is going
through some Democrats Minds when they
look at this would they like a trump
Biden contest with Trump facing criminal
charges or do you think they're sort of
wary as well about how these charges
perhaps making Trump into sort of a
martyr for certain sections of of
America I think there are mixed thoughts
going on in the minds of Democrats and
Democratic strategies I think at one
level they think yes Trump as the
nominee is good for us because that
drives out the anti-trump vote which is
huge uh and there's no point
underestimating that it's a very
significant thing
and at the same time they'll be looking
at the polls if you look at polls
comparing DeSantis against Biden with
Trump against Biden Trump actually fares
a little bit better right
um so it's possible that in the Run of
an election campaign DeSantis is a more
normal politician without all these
criminal indictments hanging over him
would fare better but that's a difficult
judgment call so I think
um I remember Megan Kelly saying to me
on spectator TV uh in answer to this
question be careful what you wish for
that's what I'd say to democratic
strategists who think Trump is the ideal
nominee if the economy
goes bad leads to indications that the
American economy is actually going quite
well but as the economy turns bad and
you have Trump versus Biden there's a
very significant chance as Neil Ferguson
said in The Spectator cover piece
recently that Trump will win and become
president again he sort of reminded of
trump of Democrats willing Trump to get
the Republican nomination the first time
round actually and if the whole coming
collapsing down because they originally
thought he'd be a better opponent well
that's that's a very that's a very good
point the interesting thing is is this a
repeat of 2016. uh and I don't think it
is in many ways because I think the
atmosphere is different because Trump in
2016 was mind-blowing I mean he still is
in many ways but but it was all so new
and and it excited a lot of people and
got people interested in politics who
weren't interested and drove outloads of
people who don't normally vote
in 2024
yes Trump's movement is much bigger
but our independence and moderates
um as interested
in the kind of trump the justice system
is against me rhetoric
I think that's a that's a question that
yet that's yet to be answered and you
mentioned Trump's one of Trump's
opponents in the Republican race Mike
Pence who's who's come out against Trump
now and and is sort of revealing his
memos from his time in the White House
the other I mean I had to say his
Republic other Republican candidates
opponents haven't made much hay of his
criminal convictions
um and do you think that's a mistake
that they're not making more political
Capital out of it uh I didn't think so
no because I think uh politics is tribal
in America now and I think that um Pence
I'm not quite sure what his strategy is
it seems like he's cooperating with the
special prosecutor Jack Smith
um and he will probably give some sort
of statement in trial maybe witnessing
trial uh and say you know recount or
he'll have notes of what his
conversations with Trump at the time and
the prosecution and Pence will try to
paint Mike Pence as vice president as a
sort of honorable man uh you know being
put under pressure by this demonic
forces Donald Trump
um I don't think that's going to
convince a lot of people Mike Pence
sucked up to Donald Trump for four years
yeah uh in the most Alliance manner
possible
um and now he wants to be president but
he's on three percent in the polls I
didn't quite get what he's thinking as
to whether this will flip the script to
him because Trump's support is around 35
to 40 percent of the party now or people
that vote Republican uh that's not going
to change and doesn't there's nothing
that seems to be shifting that brilliant
thank you very much Freddie great
pleasure
[Music]
thank you
foreign